[Applause]
well hi this is danielle dimartino booth
welcome back to down the middle uh i i'm
in red today are the markets in red
that's a good question
um
in any event i am so excited to have
peter cicchini with me he's the director
of research at exonic but he has had a
long and and and storied wall street
career and well i learned something
about peter and that's that he was a
lawyer at some point um so i'd love to
go back and get a little bit of of your
history and what uh what landed you in
finance uh and eventually here at axonic
and what you like about exonic's
investment philosophy that drew you to
the company
sure uh it's great to see you danielle
um thanks for having me uh
always great to catch up um yeah you
know it has been a while that um that
i've been doing this i did start out as
a laura i graduated from law school in
1995 and
thereafter
did a brief stint in banking and then
moved quickly into consulting
a private firm that consulted for the
department of defense as well as
manufacturers that sold to the
department of defense
um and it was a very interesting five or
so years where um you know i was focused
on a lot of different topics but but
became uh really interested in in
geo geopolitical issues
but i always had an interest in uh
finance um you know starting with the
internship that i've mentioned
and
after about five years as a consultant i
decided it was time to get back into it
um went to columbia business school and
and uh graduated on the heels of a
recession and so
um yeah i it was in 2002 and so so i
ended up working for a distressed hedge
fund which was eventually purchased by
mellon financial and then
ended up
running uh the liquid distressed group
there
um i did that for a few years and
started my own hedge fund
and from there uh you know the financial
crisis happened and oh yeah
small funds weren't able to really raise
a lot of money back then and
you know our cost structure wasn't quite
right either and so so uh we wound it
down
uh and i ended up at cantor fitzgerald
as a result and spent 10 years there as
the
global market strategist
um
it was a good ten years uh but i really
had an itch to get back to the buy side
uh all this of course happening in the
midst of a pandemic of course um and
axonic uh the founder's name is clay d
jacinto
he and i he was a client of mine and um
we worked closely together
you know valued each other's uh
intellect and um
after the pandemic sort of
uh ran its course it i guess it really
hasn't yet but but when things calmed
down a bit right we decided it would be
a good time for us to start working
together and he hired me
to come in and do a number of things i'm
the director of research here um but i'm
really focused obviously as i was a
canner on markets
um and the risk that those markets um
pose potentially to our
uh portfolio um and in that light i'm
always thinking about risk mitigation
strategies and and how we can um
uh make sure that our books are well
protected against
um both known and unknown risks uh so i
help out with that and of course i i do
things like this to try to help
um make uh axonic a little bit more of a
a well-known brand
and you know of course happy to talk a
little bit more about exonics
specifically
when you're ready well um
so i i do like that i do like the idea
of approaching investing
with risk management in mind uh
especially in a world when
you for so many years now you just need
to need to just be out there and be long
just in general just just go be long
but but we've had an extraordinary
run in markets and you you rightly uh
have have identified if you will
kind of this
and there's actually a number for it for
43.2 percent of gdp was jammed into the
veins of the economy in the space
of 18 months
and that really culminated in april and
it shaped your view of of the stock
market in particular headed into 2021
you saw what was coming walk us through
this kind of fiscal thrust because i
don't know that that there's a great
enough appreciation of the role fiscal
has played because everybody says the
fed's got your back but this really
didn't have as much to do with the fed i
think as the average investor perceives
yes yeah that that's exactly right and
frankly it also shaped my choice for
coming to axonic because i felt that we
were going to get inflationary thrust
and um exonic specialized we're
multi-asset manager of about
uh 4.6 billion and we specialize in
structured products which includes you
know cmbs rmbs it's direct lending
aircraft abs for example
but collateralized cash flowing assets
we have quite a bit of exposure to
multi-family
all of this all of these sorts of assets
tend to do better in inflationary
environments
and i really felt like while people have
gotten very comfortable with equities
for
uh over a decade as an asset class in
which one simply couldn't lose because
of the fed backstop felt like the free
lunch was was um was probably going to
come to an end in the near future
and um you know the once the lunch
lady's name is inflation and inflation
is going to demand
uh you know her fair share of
uh of forward returns
and yes the fiscal impulse in particular
um was extremely important there are
really i think at least based on my work
you know two things
that lead to an unusual situation in
which one could get inflation right and
and for context i had really been in the
disinflation slash deflation camp for a
very long time
and it was only until these two uh these
two sort of conditions
um showed themselves uh
to be real and manifest that i got
worried about inflation you know you can
look at inflationary episodes and they
usually happen during times of war and
there are two things you get you get
massive uh deficit spending
which leads to um massive expansions in
both private and public lending we have
that now
and an inorganic if you will demand
impulse
and then you also get supply chain
disruptions
and interestingly enough in this case
those supply disruptions are even
more prominent and important than they
were during
uh during wartime even during during
world wars uh there were parts of the
globe that weren't particularly affected
but in this particular instance there's
almost no escaping the shortages and
supply chain disruptions that the
pandemic has caused and so with those
two with those two um pillars of
inflation in place i started talking
about it in you know february march of
of 2021 and it was met with a very very
cold shoulder from just about any
everybody because inflation is so
unusual mm-hmm
for our entire careers it's you know
we've seen falling interest rates that's
what everybody's used to
that's right and and look you know i
think the other thing that
this episode seems to be proven right
and i don't think you can ignore
uh well over five percent cpi we just
got core today at
at 4-3
i don't think you can ignore the fact
that in that that
monetary policy both in europe and the
us and japan has not been successful at
catalyzing inflation and near the zero
bound there's not a heck of a lot that
development central banks have left
so really what was responsible for this
inflationary impulse in my view was
fiscal policy um now that creates an
interesting question right we have the 6
trillion it's
it's it's made its way through the
system in large part and you know we we
can see that in a bunch of different
ways we can see it through
the diminution in household savings we
can see it through the cash balance and
the treasury general account right
um
so from that perspective potentially
uh there won't be as much of an
inflationary problem going into next
year however
the supply side dynamics are arguably
even worse somehow than they were with
an energy crunch beginning to manifest
both in china and in europe and
potentially that can bleed
through to the united states coal prices
and natural gas prices
are at all time highs you know coal at
216 bucks a metric ton natural gas at
the equivalent of you know something
like a hundred dollars a barrel in crude
oil terms
so you know
these things have me
continually concerned that inflation
will not be
and one or two things will happen right
danielle i mean it'll either be
that inflation kills itself off
because demand will fall on higher
prices or the fed will finally be able
to act or finally be forced in a way to
act
by tapering very quickly and hiking
rates potentially before anyone might
have expected so either way inflation
inflation's going to end up being
transitory i think that's a
transitory inflation to me is a very
tautological term of course it's
transitory it can't hang around forever
because it either dies kills itself or
or a central bank will kill it
but in the meantime for stocks and not
all stocks not not every single sector
but
broadly speaking inflationary episodes
throughout history have not been good
for the riskiest assets including stocks
and have been much better for hard
assets
um like housing like commercial real
estate um and so that that really has
been the focus of of much of my work of
late
so you know you you've made an
interesting observation uh if we could
go back to
um
kind of the
what drove the spending
uh and you mentioned the role that
social media played
and it was really extraordinary to see
the lines
i live in dallas texas um you live in
new york but there were lines around the
gucci stores there were lines around the
chanel stores there were there were
there were buzzes all over social media
when these big stimulus checks uh would
hit you know via direct deposit i mean
there's nothing is there's nothing as
direct and and
but but
but it was interesting that you actually
made the connection i never thought
about it between social media and how
quickly prices rose
yeah i think there's there's two things
to unpack there the first is that we've
never seen fiscal stimulus
of this magnitude six six ish trillion
so far
not including what might be coming
which i think will be far less effective
by the way right um because as you
pointed out
they were it was much much of it was in
the form of either direct deposits into
consumers checking accounts
or direct lines of credit that
businesses could buy
and importantly through this little
thing called section 13 3 of the federal
reserve act act it was a combined effort
and arm-in-arm effort between
the treasury and the federal reserve
effectively you mentioned you said it
this way one time which i really liked
um a basically a leveraged uh a
leveraged buyout of sorts where
you know treasury funded these special
purpose vehicles right it was a
leveraged buyout of corporate america i
mean yeah that's really what it was
that's right and i loved the way you
said that and it and it resonated with
me and it and it that's really what it
was and it provided almost an implicit
guarantee for corporate america for a
time and that's one of the reasons why
credit right now
is not really
the same sort of leading indicator that
it has been in most cycles because i
think there there's just so much
confidence that no matter what happens
the fed and the treasury will step back
in again
and that has obviously sort of
reflexively continued to support to
support equities but again
you can't get away from the fact that
that fiscal impulse that you mentioned
um
will have an impact that i don't think
the fed will be able to escape and by
the way
equities took on a life of their own
which is another reason there's such a
disconnect between the credit markets
and equity markets through social media
and mean stocks in particular are sort
of
they're the emblem they're the badge for
the irrationality in the markets when
you look at how they became in a way how
equities became the tail that wagged the
credit market dog
something that i never thought i would
say you look at something like amc
or gamestop stop when amc was
essentially able for at the money uh
equity offerings
able to issue well over a billion
dollars in shares which liquefied the
company
and enabled them to refinance
essentially all of their debt
um and there was even there were even
headlines today that they're going to be
buying back first first lien term loan
so
you know all of these things combined in
a radically different way this cycle so
you know psychoanalysis i'm sorry but
meme and reddit and
chat rooms and kids in their parents
basements playing with stimulus money
and and and robin i mean it's this makes
day trading look like it was something
really boring in 1999
yeah it's it's it's the gen z version of
the day trading uh that the gen xers
were doing in the in the in the late 90s
right it's on your cell phone it's in
your pajamas
it's you know it's sort of the tinder
version of of it right it's yeah you're
just swiping this way or that oh yeah
you know that's i heard on uh uh you
know there's no analysis in this so
investing has really changed
no i mean i'm i'm going to interrupt for
two seconds because
one of the meme stocks got murdered and
i'm a bed bath and beyond and i'm
sitting there thinking to myself you've
got a 17 20 year old kid who's like this
bed bath and beyond's the hottest thing
in the world and yet they couldn't
probably find a bed bath and beyond if
you paid them money nor would they know
what to do if they stood if they stepped
inside one of them so it's just
or reddit or reddit uh traders you know
flying flying banners to buy amc uh uh
stock across beaches during the summer i
mean this happened
it's it's truly incredible and and it
either means that
you know things have changed for good
and fundamental fundamentals will never
matter again or they haven't
and i'm obviously in the or they haven't
camp because this isn't the first time
we've seen
um insane kinds of behaviors and you
know i i've i've actually likened it
not to the tulip bubble because that
arguably wasn't actually all that broad
a phenomenon back back in the 1600s with
no twitter
the south sea bubble is an interesting
analog because
you know
the people who who wanted to buy
south sea company stock
wanted to be like
the elites
and
um they they were given the opportunity
by the elite
uh you know to participate in something
and it's kind of the same thing here
like
quote this
democratization of finance that happened
through robert robin hood and
and and you know
the other stock um
uh boards like reddit
you know it's not really democratization
at all it's it's over time just i think
you know
going to lead to a lot of pain for
people who thought they could never lose
money in the stock market because at the
end of the day
when all of this fiscal stimulus starts
to fade and inflation takes its toll
it's going to be it's going to be a much
trickier environment in which to invest
and cash flows
and intrinsic value will once again
matter
it's always just a matter of time and
how long you can last
while the insanity
drives the narrative so so peter what
you are actually just describing right
now is what we have traditionally all of
our careers referred to as retail
participation and i'm not sure if you
remember the year 2000 2017 in the
markets uh you know there was a lot of
complacency the vix index the fear index
was kind of south of 10
for
for however however long it was south of
10 52 times the vix closed below 10 in
but the missing element was
retail participation it wasn't there and
we've got retail participation this time
and i think that's why one of the
reasons that you've had your eyes
specifically on small cap stocks on the
russell 2000
yeah a few reasons why since
may i've been
cautious to you know to use one word
about small caps and for the first
reason really was in inflation
um small cap stocks tend not to be able
to prep to pass through costs as readily
as large caps
and that you know that makes sense right
because they just they aren't as large
they don't have the same scale so they
don't have the same pricing power
typically
um as a large cap company in the same
space
the other
reason for caution in small caps
um was certainly the fact that um
this same sort of
mean driven retail participation tended
to concentrate small cap stocks and i
already mentioned one name amc
which is a very um uh and you know in
game stop but amc is a large component
of the russell 2000 for example
and so you know those
if i'm correct
uh and only time will tell
and we eventually revert to a world in
which things like valuation
matter again
um then small caps are also at quite a
bit of risk and interestingly enough
to put icing on that cake um the recent
rebalancing which of the of the russell
which i believe is about
now about a month old
actually happened to add a lot of
negative earnings earnings companies to
the russell 2000
so you know if you look at the russell
2000 in aggregate it's barely profitable
um
proponents of small caps would would
counter argue well that's largely
because of the pandemic
but
it's a sort of a persistent problem for
the russell 2000 that it goes in and out
of profitability even when there isn't
an economic cycle in play
yeah and i think that that is truly the
nature of small cap and small cap is
also
to me at least largely a reflection of
the the strength of the domestic u.s
economy
and that takes us right back to where we
started this discussion which was fiscal
so um i i
i want to get your views on on i want to
shift to interest rates for a second
uh because i i think
i
did i read you right that there is a
possibility that the nominal 10-year
note could go to the zero bound
that has to have been a typo
um and actually i only say that
partially tongue-in-cheek because
you know you can draw out a lot of
scenarios especially later on when we
talk about china and europe and energy
and a global slowdown you can paint the
picture we did see the tenure at 1.2
percent earlier this year um but
but so talk about nominal yields
downside and why you recently took where
you think the tenure could hit also down
in terms of the top end of your range
because they're related
yes they are so so so as you know we've
been in a an almost 40 year
secular downtrend in rates both in fed
funds as well as 10 years right 10 10
years obviously for a long time was
affected by second order
uh impacts of fed policy and if we if we
think about mathematically what the
10-year yield is
it's the geometric average of short
rates over time and so you can actually
make a case if you thought that short
rates were going to be at zero
with complete certainty
then
logically it would have to follow
that the tenure would be at zero so
what then is term premium we think about
it typically you know irving fisher's
theory of interest rates thinks about
nominal yields is real yields plus some
expectation for inflation
and i've come over the past year or so
to the conclusion that that's an
anachronistic concept for for a lot of
different reasons
and qe is really that reason
and we in fact saw
um when the 10-year went to 1.17
at one point earlier in the year
uh we we saw the fact that inflation was
clearly in the numbers
but for some reason rates were falling
not rising
and the reason for that is that the
treasury market has become
less of a market and more of a social
policy tool
because the qe allows the fed to act
directly on long yields
and that action has basically killed all
the bond vigilantes that used to
actually
um
sell bonds when they thought that there
was going to be inflation
you were literally echoing
charlie plosser former president of the
philadelphia fed he literally made a
similar statement when he was comparing
when he started out in monetary policy
and what happened in the post-qe era so
my hat's off to both of you so i'm sorry
continue
yeah well look i you know i i hate to
say it because i don't agree with the
policy prescriptions of this school of
thought but warren mosler who's you know
known as the father of mmt wrote a paper
i believe in the late 90s and it said
the natural rate of interest is zero and
he made i'm not going to get into the
arguments he made but frankly i'd been
in the camp that the natural rate of
interest was trending towards zero for
slightly different reasons than he did
but mostly because in my view over time
um it's a self it's a self-fulfilling
system that is to say
when
the the
macroeconomic
policy effect of monetary policy comes
from lower rates not low rates and so if
you're going to achieve a macro economic
outcome
rates actually have to move lower each
cycle
because the the markets the economy as
well as the financial markets
they reach an equilibrium at whatever
that new lower rate is so in order to
get a renewed or incremental
macroeconomic policy effect rates have
to be lower still
so what happens when you hit the zero
bound you can't achieve a macroeconomic
policy effect unless you move out the
curve
and take out term premia which coming
back to what i said a little bit earlier
is really more a reflection
of the fed reactions reaction function
to things like inflation then it is a
direct result of inflation itself that
is to say
rates could remain the yields the
10-year yield could remain a lot lower
than inflation would suggest if the fed
decided it wanted to continue to buy
bonds if it decided it wanted to buy
reserve it wanted to create reserves to
buy the 10-year
it could to its own at its own peril in
an inflationary environment continue to
keep rates low or yields low
while inflation continue to run high and
that's with the scenario i alluded to
earlier where i said
one or two things can happen either the
the fed or a central bank can react to
inflation or or in fact inflation can
still kill itself
by
killing demand right
we call that stagflation though don't we
yeah you know i i hesitate to use the
word stagflation because it is it is
such a loaded word and you know
literalists can say oh you know he's
talking about stagflation of the 1970s
that's absolutely ridiculous because we
still have quite a bit of gdp growth
i think it's splitting hairs
but i've avoided using it not to say
it's it's not a useful analog
um it just might not be uh like you know
history
rarely repeats but it tends to rhyme so
there are definitely parts of this piece
of music that rhyme with the 70s but
there are other parts that don't and and
the fiscal stimulus impulse
is the part that doesn't and maybe
that's a good segue to come back around
to what that looks like going forward
well
so before we do that um
you say that the fed is in denial
yeah
uh
because
you know if inflation is allowed to
to grow out of control and
home base for example the st louis fed
put out a piece uh that said that that
september non-farm payrolls could be
negative 500 000 or negative 810 000
based on a model of a real-time company
all they do is track employment moves
people in and out of buildings just in
and it's it's a a model that the st
louis fed has found to be very
helpful over time because it's it's just
it's worked as opposed to let's say adp
using that as a leading indicator not to
pick on adp
jay powell has said
that the tapering is effectively
contingent upon september payroll growth
whether or not they'll pull the trigger
in november but everything you've just
described suggests that regardless of
what payrolls are going to do
inflation's going to continue for some
time
so
again is this i mean
how long can the fed stay in denial
yeah for however long it can stay as
woke as it has been right i mean at the
end of the day oh yes
this is what's happened okay and and you
know look
i'm not i'm not taking this conversation
down down down the political route and i
don't mean to by saying that
but what's clearly started to happen is
that the employment mandate
which is a much easier mandate to wrap
one's social policy arms around has
become more important than the inflation
mandate
and because and the reason for that is
is because it's hard to know
you've had
deleterious impacts from inflation until
after the fact
right and no one's gonna you know the
fed's gonna say well you know inflation
is such a rare thing but unemployment
isn't we know we can do something about
unemployment and we want unemployment to
be low across demographic groups
and we're going to make sure that we
maintain easy policy until
all groups are employed
um but you know we're not going to worry
much about inflation because number one
it hasn't existed and there's a case to
be made
that it's not something we need to worry
about in the long run now that that's
the thing that kills me about this
transitory tautology right in
in the july 17 i believe i believe
pressure that powell had he said
you know we're only going to be worried
about inflation if it changes the
process of inflation over three to five
years well i have i you know i
i don't know maybe i just don't get it
but if we have to wait three to five
years to know whether or not
inflation has had an impact isn't it too
late
so
it seems to me like the fed has
effectively
jettisoned the inflation part of the
mandate because it's just
it's it's less
popular if you will
than making sure that they can get
employment to whatever level they decide
is full employment maybe that's zero i
don't know
but
i do think it's dancing with the devil
to ignore inflation because inflation
can have an impact on employment as well
i think
that's why i made the statement that you
know the fed is sort of ignoring it at
its peril
and that's it's really really
interesting you say that because
you uh you've been keeping a close eye
on the saving rate
and we found out that in in august the
the saving rate fell down to 9.4 percent
so we're back into single digits on the
saving rate we had been it obviously had
spiked when all of this money was
flowing into the economy you know other
work that's been done by the new york
fed for example shows that the bulk of
the
the marginal savings that still exists
is in the hands of people in their 50s
60s and 70s
so and we've still got this inflation
saving rate back below uh 10 percent uh
where's the spending capacity
going to come from i mean has can you
talk to me about the idea of
pulling forward demand
yeah sure you know one of the things
that i pointed out in a recent piece
um you know is that in fact household
savings
in absolute terms were now below
um
pre-pandemic levels
slightly
and uh you know that could indicate that
that um impulse that drove consumption
has now
is now gone um
and i think you know the
the question then becomes how quickly
can organic recovery
replace the inorganic demand impulse
which clearly pulled forward
lots of demand
i just don't think
that there's any way that can be a
seamless transition from
six trillion dollars of stimulative
demand impulse directly in the pockets
of consumers to
a recovery that's going to take time and
by the way i think one of the other
things that's being ignored in addition
to the import of six trillion dollars of
uh
deposits not completely but you know um
into people's checking accounts is the
fact that 2019
was a slowdown year
we saw you know loan growth falling off
into the end of 2019
the economic data didn't look that great
and that by the way began at the end of
2018 when there was a 20 swing in the
equity markets uh you know on on the
10-year yield in my view this is the
driver on the 10-year year yield year
yield rising to three and a quarter
percent or so
and the yield curve inverted
and the economy slowed and so this idea
that we were somehow on a gangbusters
growth trajectory before the pandemic
hit
i think is is an incorrect assumption
and so to think that we're going to go
back to some
blockbuster level of pre-pandemic growth
doesn't make an awful lot of sense to me
it doesn't and you know
something that that lacy hunt
taught me
and i've spoken to him over the years is
that if global trade ever contracts for
the full year the united states is
heading into recession and he just went
back to me and showed me the examples
and the you know the double-dip
recession of the 80s etc well global
contraction
global trade contracted for the full
year in 2019 so that train had left the
station but there are a lot of
denialists especially in your world who
call it the pandemic recession well
yeah pandemic recession created a heck
of a lot of fiscal stimulus as as we
know um
so
a a mutual friend peter bookfar
noted that if you adjust for inflation i
think people have a hard time grasping
the idea of real or inflation-adjusted
data but he made he made the comment if
you ingest if you adjust for inflation
and you look at the combination of july
and august
consumer spending in the united states
it was flat as a pancake
yes that that's absolutely right i i
agree with that analysis
um and you know moreover
um when you and i've never seen this
happen before when you look at
high yield real yields for example
they're deeply negative
so
you know
you know and again this is where
it is important to try to understand how
long inflation is going to last because
people can't tolerate
um
you know negative high yield returns
for
much longer something has to break
something has to give
and it doesn't necessarily guarantee
that in order to get that yield people
are going to migrate to equities
when i think again coming back for a
second to equities you know margins are
are at their peak
and inflation likely and especially
again for those companies not well
positioned to pass it through the
consumer
um
will compress and i think that's you
know that's a very a very big risk
uh when thinking again about how
inflation sort of change when you take
inflation into account as peter did in
his analysis
really changes the entirety of the
entirety of the of the analysis
it does it's and and i
you know
i read a commentary a few days ago that
said you know
a record number of companies had
mentioned inflation in their earnings
conference calls
and that you know therefore the
inflation you know it's it's already
priced in into the market uh
that may be the case but the margin
compression that you note that's coming
is certainly not priced into the market
yeah i think that was probably my
morning note because
it was you know it's interesting to see
you know you could see it anecdotally um
large multinationals were starting to
point it out uh ppg etc
and
it was tough to to actually
try to aggregate that and in fact our
friends at bloomberg came up with a tool
that enables one to do that and actually
go through uh earnings
uh transcripts um and and actually try
to quantify that and it's not just at an
all-time high it's at you know a
considerably higher all-time high and
it's not to say it's going to abate
because the way companies typically do
this is they will
they'll test the market right so they'll
raise prices by a little bit they'll see
what the impact on demand is and they'll
do it again and again and again until
they feel like they can't do it anymore
and so i think that's just the beginning
um and companies are in fact signaling
that in their earnings reports but but
it doesn't mean it's priced in it simply
means that there's likely more to come
yeah i mean i was i i was i was shocked
at how shocked the market was
when cox automotive came out and said
well nearly half of would-be car buyers
in the united states
are suffering from sticker shock so
they're they're postponing their their
you know their plans to
to to buy a car oh and by the way car
prices have been at record highs for
five months in a row and i'm like you
can't look at those two in isolation
that's impossible i mean car prices have
never ever been new car prices as high
as and and it's clear that the
manufacturers are just
they're just like you said experimenting
well you know personal experience for a
second um
you know i'm long too many cars as it is
but
you know i i have a car that i lease
which i use here in the city
and it's coming off lease and i thought
well i must be in the money on my
release residual and you know
um they should be able to credit that to
a new vehicle right um and or obviously
if you're in the money on your residual
you can
you know
buy the car out of your lease right
right sell sure okay and make some money
that's a hassle that none of us are
gonna do for five or six thousand
dollars right ten thousand dollars even
but the bottom line is you you're not
going to get a better lease deal on your
new car because in fact
new car prices manufacturers are not
stupid
they're raising new car prices so that
you can't r be residual that's of course
that's what happens right
so and by the way it's not just cars and
and you know much of do was made a
couple months ago and cpi came out a
tenth of a percent
uh lower than than previous print and
you know then ppi came out on the heels
of that much hotter and what the ppi
print showed and has continued to show
is that inflation is actually broadening
it's not just used cars and computer
chips it's moving into lots of other
areas and if you look at ppi which tends
to lead cpi by a little bit in terms of
the way
that broadens sure um it doesn't feel
like inflation is abating and i think
the core the core number that came out
today uh supports that alongside by the
way the new york fed's own surveys for
future expectations of inflation and
michigan which i think has been ahead of
the curve
on people's expectations for both one
and three to five year inflation you've
been saying that the university of
michigan uh
kind of
defies what jay powell
is has been saying at the podium and
that is that u.s households are aware
that inflation has arrived and that it's
it's it's something that is tangible to
them
yeah i mean you know there's a a piece
uh not to get too nerdy about it but
there's a piece of the search
for it
which says you know uh how do you feel
about your income keeping pace with
prices and people overwhelmingly
responded their income is not keeping
pace with prices full stop
and you know again you can see this
anecdotally uh you know which is and
it's likely going to affect low end
consumers more in a lot of ways but for
the first time in a very long time
dollar tree said it was going to raise
its prices above the dollar price point
we all know that's kind of a silly thing
the dollar whatever but they're raising
prices and that likely means that other
low-cost retailers are going to raise
their prices which means that the higher
margin goods that they sell that you
know that hello kitty pen you know you
were there with your daughter or
whatever she said i love that can you
get that for me sure
you know if you're spending a lot more
money on the necessities you're not
going to make that impulse purchase
purchase by which by the way that's
where they make all their margin right
right so you know i think that
process of companies just starting to
starting to raise prices we're in the
beginning of that
not not at the end quite yet it takes
time for it to make its way through the
value chain fully to the consumer
well um so so this kind of
leads me to the subject of
of jobs
and i'm i'm intrigued you said that
twitter is toxic and i'm just going to
share a little story so every single
time i'm on twitter and mention that you
know the job market might
that you know that those 10 tr those 10
million job openings that that might
over advertise what's happening in the
job market
and in fact there might be weakness
coming down the pipeline because
companies
don't just take margin compression
sitting down uh you know they they try
to
in addition to raising prices they try
to cut costs and so we have seen uh a
lot of automation but the reason i bring
twitter up is because every time you put
it out there
that anything about wages you get these
these nasty answers that say well then
it's time for corporate america to pay
up
and it's past time
but that doesn't really work when you
have shareholders involved and so i'm
curious what your outlook is for
the job market given we've got you know
we we've just had initial claims go up
for three weeks in a row state initial
claims where did that come from so i'm
curious what your outlook is there
yeah you know look social media is what
it is
and um generally speaking if
your narrative
is even slightly to the right or the
left of the
popular narrative especially when it
comes to stock market or jobs uh or
whatever
um you know
the attempt to cancel you is is is quite
great
and um
often it's just oftentimes just not
worth the time to even participate in
the nonsensical dialogue that occurs
that's true
yeah so so you know look there's there's
always been
you know a tension between capital and
labor so i'm not surprised that that is
the
reaction in social media to whenever
uh the topic comes up um it's a it is a
long-running tension that literally
um
underpins the difference between
socialism
uh and capitalism so so look
can companies
continually pass through benefits to
workers at the expense of profits
clearly the answer is
no i mean that's that's obviously an ex
would be an extreme situation but
companies clearly have to walk the line
to make sure that they reward workers
for
their
productive endeavors
and there's nothing wrong with that a a
well-run company should compensate its
workers well
and at the end of the day that i don't
think is at all inconsistent with the
goal
of rewarding shareholders for their
investment and so i think there's
actually a
large overlap between the interests of
capital and labor
capital cannot um
cannot earn a long run
return
without labor
and likewise labor
will not be well compensated without
capital
and so that tension is a good tension in
a lot of ways um unfortunately in
situations where
you have inflation
it brings that tension to the forefront
because
rather than be a win-win between capital
and labor it feels much more like a
zero-sum game right and that's the
problem because at some point if
inflation is severe enough
companies have to either raise prices or
try to cut wages or do something else
to maintain their margins because they
do have a fiduciary obligation to
shareholders and so that's the really
tricky
part
of managing an uh as a company's
management in an inflationary
environment
well um and we're definitely as you said
closer to the beginning of that process
which i i think is
underappreciated
but um
shift gears for a minute uh
everybody says the dollar is going to
hell in a hand basket
uh what what is your medium term outlook
uh for the dollar given given where you
think rates are headed
yeah i've been a dollar bull for some
time um you know last year in particular
people were
were concerned that the dollar was was
going to
depreciate significantly the most
important thing i think to recognize
is that especially in a
global crisis
currency crosses are relative value
assessments
and at the end of the day there is and
probably will remain for some time
whether whether other economies like it
or not there will remain a global dollar
shortage
a structural shortage of dollars
based on the way the world reorganized
after world war ii effectively
and of course rate differentials matter
um but the fact of the matter is
relative to developed market currency
crosses rates in other developed
economies like japan and in europe are
much lower than they are in the united
states
um when it comes to emerging market
economies
uh a rate differential comparison
can't be made directly because you have
to then introduce a new concept which is
risk premium right
so
when your risk
of owning one currency versus the other
is unequal then you have to take that
into account and so relative to even
emerging market currencies i think the
dollar will remain well bid because
there's not going to be enough in in
this kind of environment where there are
a lot of tail risks to covet and
otherwise
and especially because there's inflation
which can just absolutely demolish
emerging market economies the dollar
will likely remain relatively well bid
even if my thesis over the long run
were to be that
you know rates tended towards zero and
by the way just to clarify
the the shorter term view is that rates
will continue to grind higher on taper
um but
moderated by the fact that in this
particular instance right taper is not
the taper of 2018 where the fed was
shrinking its balance sheet it's simply
fewer asset purchases meaning the
balance sheet is growing less quickly
right so it's a very different kind of
taper so
moderated by that to some extent but
also moderated by the fact that
an equity risk off which could come from
things like margin compression
would likely catalyze um capital flows
from
equities into things like the long end
of the u.s treasury curve which is one
of the few places you can get a uh you
know any any sort of risk-free return
um that has a positive nominal yield
forget about the real yield
um
there seems to be a a small little
energy crisis brewing
around the world uh
i actually caught a bloomberg interview
in which you were you were sharing some
of your views on energy
but you know it's it's start here in the
united states
and then you know take us out to europe
and england and china
and what's what some of these rising
energy prices as we head into the winter
what that can possibly mean
for inflation but also in the grander
scheme of things for the global economic
outlook
yeah and you know look i think i think
the energy shortest is part and parcel
of the supply chain disruptions that um
we've been concerned with for some time
so
it doesn't necessarily come as that much
of a surprise but clearly coming into
winter seeing what natural gas prices
are doing and seeing what coal prices
are doing
it has great import
fortunately for the united states only
about 20 percent of our energy needs are
served by coal now
but
in china it's very much not the case you
know whereas
between 50 and 60 percent or even higher
perhaps of their energy needs are met by
coal
and their need for coal is what's
driving coal prices higher
and in much of the world the baseline
um
provision of energy is still coal
and so that has
a real impact on
the cost of everything right the cost of
manufacturing
uh widgets to iphones and in fact you
know
that was one of the headlines i came
across just a few days ago that you know
one of the supply chain partners for
apple may not be able to deliver on
iphone supply because of the energy
curtailment in china
and so that's how you know these energy
um supply shortages can can affect
everything from not just how much it it
costs to heat your home in the in the
winter but
you know the price of an iphone or its
availability
it goes much deeper than just
again
your heating bill and how much it cost
to fill your car's gas tank
so it's interesting
that you framed this uh because a few
days ago i published about the effect
that the olympics
coming on the 4th of february in china
that that's really going to make this
energy situation go from bad to worse
because they have to clear up the smog
in
in beijing
which means i mean the rest of the
country can be you know smog-filled and
it's regular but they have to use
alternative forms of energy until they
get through the month of february so
it's i'll just add that little twist if
you will that's interesting that's an
interesting point i hadn't considered
yeah and well i mean if you look back at
2008 we saw a very similar run-up to the
summer olympics in beijing um
but
but bigger picture
china is still the marginal buyer of
commodities worldwide
it is what it is so how does this how
does this how should this affect our
outlook
i would say near term
for for commodities i'm talking about
commodities outside of natural gas uh
coal anything energy related ex energy
commodities
yeah well you know it's interesting we
talked a little bit earlier about how
rates markets have changed because of
the fed's participation
um since the end of the gfc if anybody
can remember that far back
um you know china really took on a new
role as a world power and grew gang
musters after the great financial crisis
relative to
develop market counterparts
and it really took over
as the world's biggest consumer and
producer of most commodities when you
look at copper more than 50 percent of
the world's copper is produced and
consumed by china that blows me away
yeah coal same thing you know you could
name a half dozen commodities and so you
know copper in particular is an
interesting case because
you know people used to reference and
some people still do
but people used to refer to it as dr
copper because it was supposed to tell
you a lot about
um what global supply and demand looked
like at any given time
for better or worse now a big move in
copper probably has more to do with
what china is doing and whether or not
there has been a decision by central
authorities in china to buy or sell
copper and they typically will
stockpile commodities they feel like
they may need so if they're right about
the global demand forecast then perhaps
it does presage
um
you know a
an increase in demand globally but they
may be doing it for other reasons as
well um because they don't think just
next quarter
or even next
six months they're thinking
you know how much copper do we need for
the next three to five years how much
coal do we need for the next three to
five years do we need to stockpile this
and copper also serves another purpose
in china
which is contract for different
difference collateral and so it's also
something of a financial asset so so all
these things are you know a little bit
more complicated to analyze than they
were 20 years ago before china took such
a prominent role in the commodity
markets so um
bring all of this together
you uh
you're not i don't i don't want to paint
you as a bearer like in every corner of
the market you're pretty sanguine
especially when it comes to i'm looking
out you know the back of your window and
i see i see shadows of buildings um
you're pretty sanguine on multi-family
can you talk a little bit about that
thesis given
we see castle with a k
uh
you know the the office occupancy in new
york is 29 it's lower than that in san
francisco the highest it is is it is in
houston and in dallas and that's 50
percent
um so
help me square that circle in terms of
your bullishness on multi-family
yeah well look it it's actually been a
view i've had for some time uh even
before i arrived at axonic and of course
it's it's core to what axonic does but
we're not just buying multi-family
anywhere right the one of the one of the
nice things about the real estate market
is
it's a market which is has
uh geographic specificity and idiot
idiosyncratic idiosyncratic
characteristics which investors can take
take advantage of unlike a lot of public
markets right now no sense and
multifamily in partic particular
if you choose the right geographies and
the right
uh the right securities with which to
express the view
can provide
a
very safe cash flowing alternative
to just about anything else that has the
same yield
and the multi-family thesis is certainly
well supported by the fact that housing
prices have gone up 20 percent year over
year
and that lack of affordability is
driving people
into multi-family as renters
and as a result
both the collateral values uh for
existing multi-family properties in
which we're invested for example or
indeed um for stuff that's coming down
the pipeline
is is more valuable because rents are
rising
with home prices and and interestingly
this comes back to the inflation uh
discussion that we had earlier which is
to say
rents owner's equivalent rent really
hasn't risen with home prices yet but it
will because it always does
it does it with a lag because obviously
people usually have one to two year
leases
um and so it takes a little bit of time
for those higher house prices to
actually bleed into rents but that's one
of the things we like about the outlook
for multifamily the fact that we think
in the right markets let's not talk
about new york and san fran and some of
the others but in the right markets
which we do deep fundamental analysis to
identify we think that rents are going
to go up interesting good and because
there is there's still a lot of supply
coming online in the wrong places and
that's why
you're pointing out location location
location also applies you know to
multi-family and and but the other
aspect you bring up is
kind of how ridiculous
the fed's
view of inflation is because there is
such a long lead time between when home
prices which we were told by k shiller
we're going up 19.7 percent all time you
know in
and apartment class a rents are going up
uh double digits right now so but but
it's it's
to me it's it's it's almost insulting to
investors to say it's all supply chain
it's all transitory i mean in july how
many times did he use the word lumber uh
because it had come off of its highs
which it's still 34
higher than it was at least but anyway
thank you for pointing that out well i
mean i mean thank you
yes but but it just seems a little
disingenuous to
deny that
housing plays such a large
role it's 40 of the cpi
lucky for them it's half of that in the
pce
um very convenient but but it's still
very real and i think that it goes back
to university of michigan and
households awareness
yes look
people need to
sustain themselves and the two basic
things they need to sustain themselves
are food
and clothing of course and housing
and so
uh
in the right markets uh you know there
is pricing power
and interestingly enough
even in markets that you might think
have an oversupply of multi-family
housing like for example you might think
that work from home
um has decimated the new york city
rental market it hasn't
um rental prices for
most size departments okay especially
the lower end are actually higher than
they were
pre-pandemic it's it's hard to believe
but it's absolutely positively the fact
well i pound the table all the time
because the media loves the work from
home theme
but the bureau of labor statistics will
tell you that it topped out somewhere
around 40 maybe 45 percent and it's down
to 13. so move on people because i think
a lot of people have moved back into
cities yes i agree and by the way we
also think there's opportunity in office
for that very reason we think the work
from home uh you know narrative is is
overplayed
interesting
so um let's let's step back and go
really big picture because i think your
your focus on fiscal is so critical
because
you know you have to ask yourself what
happens next and i'll tell you about a
guy by the name of pat toomey so he's a
senator who believes in term limits and
what few people
appreciated about that
late
stimulus package was that he put
stipulating language in the legislation
that said that janet yellen
he was he was referring to whoever the
next treasury secretary was was going to
be but right now in in the case it's
janet yellen at the be at the behest of
jay powell cannot flip the switch back
on these credit facilities
there has to be very well there has to
be a new 13c there has to be a new form
of emergency it can't just be oh gee the
credit markets are starting to fall out
of the bed because they're finally
figuring out that there's a slowdown in
in the us economy without the fiscal
thrust so here's
post gfc post-financial crisis the fed
went out of the loan
and was able to successfully address
liquidity systemic risk contain
everything get the ball rolling
quantitative easing blow the markets
back up more financialization blah blah
blah but this time it took fiscal and
fed policy and so i don't know that
what's your philosophy about what
happens if there's a hiccup
and i don't want i don't want you to be
political but as we're heading into what
could possibly be
a rancorous midterm election
i mean what what role will the fed be
able to play i think is what i'm saying
if fiscal can't
be there
no
absolutely and this is this has been a
big part of my theme
uh really since the beginning of the
year
and you know i started out the year
actually fairly bullish at equities into
july in late july i put out a piece
where i said you know where
we become we become uh
relatively
uh bearish of equities broadly broadly
speaking again there are pockets that we
like
but but that said one of the reasons is
that the fed
the fed's ability again to affect
a macroeconomic outcome near the zero
bound
with both fed funds as well as 10-year
yields this low
um is limited when we think about
previous recessions the fed was able to
cut on average in a range of between
five and seven percent to affect the
desired macroeconomic outcome right and
there's a misperception that the fed
doing qe
in and of itself somehow is stimulative
it's not correct
the fed itself many within the fed have
said
the quantity of money is not what does
it folks it's the impact on treasury on
treasury purchases that drives down
yields so what the fed does is it
creates a reserve which becomes a
liability on its balance sheet it uses
the new frns or cash to go out and buy
treasuries and by buying treasuries it
creates
it does two things it creates demand for
its for treasuries in and of itself by
the act of buying them and also creates
some something of a scarcity in
treasuries for private buyers and that
lowers interest rates right it's the
interest rate mechanism that we have to
care about and there's just not a ton of
room
on 10 years and by the way when you get
close to
zero on the long end it's not very good
for banks and so they're diminishing
marginal returns because banks lend on a
spread
so you know at zero you may have that
stimulative impact of ten year going
from one and a half to zero um
with respect to consumption and and
you know increased desire to lend and
borrow
but the profitability of those loans
right is it aired greatly so there's a
huge offset so yeah and in fact i'm
going to ask you to send it and we'll
pop up the graph here in the end because
you've done some great work on loan
demand
yeah look what the other
misunderstanding is is that somehow
banks can force loans into the system
that's not the way it works
loan demand creates lending and loan
volume there has to be
a demand for the loans
even during the pandemic you know
how come there isn't more update on
uptake on some of our lending facilities
well because the demand wasn't there you
can't force loans on people if the
if if the organic
reason for taking out a loan is not
there then it's very difficult to get
people to borrow and in fact you don't
want them to borrow if they don't have a
reasonable need for it right
so so that's really important which
takes us to i think your main your main
point here which is that
it comes down to fiscal policy right and
and so with monetary policy
very close to doing and having done
everything it can
fiscal policy makers need to step up and
look they did they did in during the
pandemic
and you know you can argue it was a
couple trillion too much or too little
um but they did what they needed to do
to prevent a complete catastrophe from
occurring
the problem is once again there are no
free lunches at some point
you have to pay for that for that
stimulus and that it's either through
taxes or through inflation by the way
inflation is a form of a tax right of
course right so
what's going to happen next uh on the
fiscal files policy front is probably
better left to experts in the in that
area but i will i will make a general
statement and i will say
whether it's 3.5 trillion
or a trillion and a half 550 plus the
trillion that mansion is now discussing
as being feasible given his you know
reticence to to do the three and a half
it almost doesn't matter danielle and
the reason for that is because
most of the money
is going to be either pork barrel or
infrastructure right now
i'm a big proponent of infrastructure
spending don't get me wrong i think it's
great if it's real
and it makes its way to projects but two
things it's notoriously
again
pork belly it notoriously does not make
its way
to construction companies who actually
fix the roads and bridges that's the
first thing the second thing is it
happens over a very long period of time
so we're talking over 10 years
okay trillion dollars you know 100
billion a year okay that's that's
significant but it's nothing
close to the order of magnitude that we
got with six trillion dollars of
relatively direct stimulus over the
course of a year and change
and i think um we're going to end on
that note but but and you and that's
that's something you
you you said in the very beginning of
our discussion is but it's spread out
and
you know that i know that
i don't know necessarily that it's fully
incorporated because people are like we
need that stimulus it was six then it
could be three or four and a half
trillion now
but the critical distinction is when
it's spread out all over time and it's a
the big dig in boston and using public
unions and all the all of the different
things you hear about every time there's
major public spending projects
that's not going to have the same impact
and i think i think the fact that you
bring that up and you you weave the
fiscal side uh into your analysis is so
critical so um so i i'm
enjoying your research i'm happy you're
at exotic
i am uh i am in i'm doing my very first
post covid
um
post fomc so that wednesday whatever
that wednesday is november the 3rd
so i'm going to do my very first ideas
dinner in the post covet era so i hope
like you have in the past you can join
me and we can we can talk again but
thank you so much today for your views
uh this has been a great visit
thank you danielle it's always a
pleasure thanks so much thanks take care
bye bye
peter jacini i mean what a great
thinker such a great hour that we were
just able to spend with him
and again the takeaway here is
it's not so much the fiscal spending
it's not so much what the government has
injected into the u.s economy in the
last two years call it it's how it's
been injected directly into the veins of
u.s consumers and that compares really
it's a complete and total distinction
from what we're talking about going
forward which is
long infrastructure spending spread out
over a decade so i hope you enjoyed his
views i learned a lot i hope you did as
well if if you want to look at more of
the geopolitical angle of some of the
things that are going to be facing the
global economy as we end 2021 and look
to 2022 go back and look at the at the
interview that i did watch the interview
that i did with peter scheer recently in
new york and i think he'll give you some
great insights on that front and as
always i thank you for your time and i
look forward to the next down down the
middle this is danielle demartino booth
[Music]